[Music]
hour two of this wednesday pft live
and the deal was done yesterday i'd say
bengals fans were getting a little bit
nervous about what was going on with joe
burrow
and the cincinnati bengals first overall
pick in the draft but
they got it done there was never any
indication of any acrimony or
whatever burrow signs and it makes sense
for him to sign
look there was a thought that maybe you
sit out the whole year re-enter the
draft but it doesn't make sense
because the salary cap's to go down next
year you're not going to get a better
deal than the one that's on the table
right now you get the bulk of your money
and signing bonus chris
so joe burrow officially a member of the
cincinnati bengals he's in the fold
along with aj green
joe mixon showed up this bengals team
has very low expectations
for 2020 they keep their guys healthy
they keep their guys away from the virus
and this is a team that could be very
interesting i know it's a tough division
to compete in but uh if they just the
key is
more than the virus just keeping guys
healthy having a healthy group of
receivers on the field something that
they really
rarely are able to do but i'm excited
about what joe burrow can do based on
what we saw him do last year for lsu
i am too uh you know again you know this
is another quarter
we talked about tua last hour right you
know hey
pandemic year yeah no otas here's a
rookie quarterback okay
you know i don't give a damn joe burrow
is in that tua class to me
of like he's about as ready to go as far
as a rookie quarterback and what it
means to play in the nfl as you're ever
going to see
you know he was in a pro-style offense
he was running sean payton's west coast
type offense last year you know not to
that extent
that level and capacity and you know
creativity but still it was that
often so he's gonna have a great
understanding of nfl offenses again
and within that offense is gonna be some
carryover
from the sean mcvay uh zach taylor type
offense too so he's gonna understand
some of the rules right away
uh and the fact that again he played in
the sec he's been around nfl football
players
um i just i'm excited for joe burrow
like like i said during the draft mike i
mean he's the closest thing
i think i've seen to peyton manning
coming out in the draft you know since
peyton manning of course
and that's just the way the aura and the
way he handles himself off the field
the way he plays on the field uh he's
just
he's got it all and it just seems like
the tougher the game the worse the
situation is whatever it is he just
rises to the challenge and
and plays better and i'm with you mike
i'm excited they got some young studs
and a guy like a.g green where you go
yeah they might lose a lot of games but
they could be really fun to watch and
put
up a lot of points in yards you know and
as we wait for more clarity or
as the case may be any clarity on what's
going to happen with college football
season this year
think about this if there hadn't been
college football season last year
where would joe burrow have been drafted
this year
right joe burrow was on no one's list as
a breakout star and a guy who was
destined to be the number one overall
pick in the draft
so it just shows you what the nfl loses
the nfl is rooting very hard for college
football to happen
because you want to have that last year
of college football
help you better crystallize what
otherwise is a complete and total crap
shoot
but yeah if there had been no football
last year no joe burrow there may be
some other guy out there who's ready to
become a star
who will be the first overall pick in
2021 that we won't even know about right
if they don't play college football this
fall so burro made the most out of that
last year of college football
and now the bengals hoping to make the
most out of their latest effort at a
franchise quarterback really their first
guy since
i don't want i don't want to you know
andy dalton was just kind of there was
he a franchise quarterback he got a
decent contract
he was with the team for what eight nine
seasons right
it just was never it just never felt
like it was clicking the way that it
does
for the teams that have a true franchise
quarterback and that's what every team
needs to get to you need to have that
quarterback that you think
is in the top ten or close to the top
ten if you want to contend everything
that's right and you're you're exactly
right and i don't think we ever had that
warm and fuzzy feeling about andy dalton
i think we might have had years where we
went ooh
andy dalton looks good whoo is andy
dalton in the top half of football
you know we might have like flirted with
that but you're right they haven't had
this type of guy since you know carson
palmer and this kind of excitement
you know so and then this is a guy
that's you know coming off in a national
championship
and you know again yeah it was not a
talented team but man did he have a lot
of highlight reel type plays that we
just showed there where
there's nothing and he's scrambling
around and running and making
unbelievable plays off schedule so
that's where he's gonna be fun because
he is i think a guy that
as you always hear me say mike he's
gonna capitalize on what the offense and
what's there to be had
but he can capitalize when there's
nothing there to be had as we had this
conversation so many times with those
top 10 guys
offensive coordinator can't call the
right play all the time so every now and
then hey
that that the defense has got you know a
pro coach and
pro players on that side too they win
sometimes you need a quarterback that a
handful of those plays
is still going to make plays when the
defense wins
and the defense is going to go damn we
had them how did they get a 20-yard gain
well i'll tell you why because that damn
quarterback's really good and i think
joe burrow
is one of those guys hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports